what is your favorite part about being a
mom my favorite part about being a mom I
mean it's so corny but it's just like no
matter how tired you are whatever you
just it's complete bliss and like no
matter what and no matter just I mean
Christmas Day I was so hung over and I
was like how am I gonna get through this
day and just when you see your baby and
how happy and like you just get through
it and I was like okay if I could do
anything I could do this and it's just
the best and just the love that you've
got you that you also get to give and
receive it's just it's beautiful there's
something about seeing the world again
through a little bit more fun yeah yeah
I think it really makes you know our
lives that get busy and things get heavy
and then to see like the innocence of a
child and I just always like I think
also motherhood just puts life into
perspective and what's important to you
and and I still think people who don't
have kids there's definitely there's
things that are important to them too
cuz I felt that way but I think you just
re-evaluate things like I don't want to
do that tonight and it's okay to say no
so I can spend time with my family give
me um your latest milestone um she
started clapping for herself so tell me
about creating a line how involved were
you were you testing the colors were you
naming were you looking at packaging how
was that business ladies absolutely I
think that's probably the most fun part
for both of us it's like anytime I was
at Chloe's house if she had makeup I was
figuring out within her palette what
would work for me if I forgot my bag and
then we randomly were gonna go out so
going through this process we decided to
create things that worked worked for
both of us worked for like best friends
that get together and get ready and glam
and how that's fun and like you like
nude I like nude but these tones spoke
work for both of us so it was it was
really fun no I love this because this
is a true like modern woman moment where
you both have different complexions but
like the fact that you could create
things that like work on both of you
yeah that's a really cool move in
different ways and we also trust the
experts at becca who know formulations
and we wanted something was really
buildable and things that you can layer
cuz she doesn't wear any makeup to the
gym it sometimes they need
and sunny you know I need a little bit
of Sun right
I need that squat glow clothes we all
want to be cute over here wow I really
trusted them with perfecting the
formulas and they're so good at that
yes but Malika and I were really adamant
about our colors and our shades and
Becca's such an easy collaboration
because they allowed us to still be very
us and we picked our names and but we
trusted them with what is the best
formulas I love that because everyone
knows Beca has affairs
[Music]